the Joe Rogan experience but they're
trying to do almost everything to limit
the amount of options that someone who
wants to have a gun has here I've seen
that's another thing that people don't
talk about because people are talking
about oh it's just it's just a lot to
make it a little bit harder well that
that should a grits mm-hmm and at a
certain point what you start doing you
start pricing people out of the market
right and so if you start adding cuz all
these laws they're not they're not free
mmm-hmm
like background checks aren't free
people don't realize that right they're
not free so you have all these little
these little fees and taxes and all this
stuff you and I'm not gonna have a
problem paying for him but you know who
will people who live in shitty
environments and don't have a lot of
money that's who's gonna have a problem
buying guns to protection who arguably
probably need them more right and people
don't understand I think about that or
people don't understand oh these are
just reasonable laws and there's nothing
unreasonable yeah but see here's the
problem you stack them on top of each
other it just becomes more of a barrier
to firearm ownership a lot of times a
lot of these laws are designed to make
it so hard and annoying to own a gun
that you just don't want to do it mmm
it's just too much and people like why
don't you like mandated training well
because I've already seen what they've
done with other laws so all that's gonna
happen is they're gonna start off with
saying okay you need three hours of
mandated training then it's gonna be
four there's gonna be seven then another
shooting will happen 20 now as somebody
who's an entrepreneur who can generally
speaking make their schedule
maybe they may be able to do that
somebody working two jobs four or five
to nine they can't take there's no way
they're gonna be able to satisfy that
right you know and people don't think
about the real implications of that and
so and even even then even from a in
inner-city perspective right people who
are talking about policing debt that we
police the inner-city too much well
where do you think they're gonna go and
enforce these laws if we have more of
them where do you think they're gonna
enforce them they're not they're not
going to to Malibu to enforce gun laws
they were enforcing them in South
Central like I mean that's just is what
it is so people don't think about the
actual real consequences of these laws
they look at them and say
that that bad it's pretty reasonable no
okay what about the other ten eleven
twelve other laws on top of that that
were considered just reasonable
[Applause]